these are the basic crafts we're going
to be inspecting and transforming the
first transformation we're going to have
a look at like I said it starts with T
and it's called translation so you need
to call back your knowledge of
year-seven geometry to remember this
word this is about a synonym for
translation it's about shifting things
or moving them around the coordinate
axes okay now for this point what I want
us to do it like I said to the people
who were prompt is please open up desmos
we're going to use it to explore the
graph that we've got here so I'm going
to pull it over here on the right hand
side I'm gonna make it a little bit
bigger because I need a bit of space to
work with here
and I have a bit more space to work with
okay so what we're gonna have a look at
now I'm going to start from the list up
from the left hand side okay and we had
y equals x and let's start by putting
that on to our axes y equals x there it
is
I made it thick enough good okay so
there's our first graph and now what I
want to do is explore well what happens
if we take away a constant a from the
right hand side of the equation so
you're hopefully familiar with this a
little bit but if you've never
encountered it before if you go into the
alphabetical keyboard in desmos and put
it in a net on the left hand side of my
dad's my screen you can see it's
prompting me to add a slider in so I can
change the value of a dynamically and
now I can see y equals x and y equals x
minus a right beside each other okay now
the reason why I want us to look at this
visually and on desmos is so that we can
actually fiddle about with a in a
dynamic way so have a look at what a is
it defaults to 1 whenever you introduce
a new premium rule and because it's
defaulted to 1 you might need to zoom in
to see this little closer what I've got
is the original graph in red the new
graph in blue and there's been a
translation from one to the other you
can see that it has moved one unit to
the right x equals y equals 1 so I've
shifted over and if you change a further
you can see I don't know what the graph
is sliding as well you can see that as I
move a further across there's a equals 5
I have now
my blue graph across as aware I've
translated to five units to the right so
when we take in the general case y
equals x minus a what we can say is
you've taken your original graph like
was X and you have translated it a units
to the right so I'm just going to come
back to my original working here and on
my page even though we've fiddled with
this in desmos I do want to actually do
a graph here I've moved over to the
right and I've moved over eight units so
that means I've got a new x intercept
it's going to be a and I've also got a
new y intercept it's going to be in this
case negative a all right so I've moved
over to the right what would we expect
when we do the parabola well again we
can explore this over here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take that y
equals x and I'm going to spare it so
there's the parabola that we had before
and then what I'm going to do here I
should have left this on the screen
sorry about that and what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna say X minus a I'm
gonna put back at around the whole thing
and I'm gonna square the entire
expression on the right-hand side so
there's a bracket there's a bracket and
then I Square now when you have a look
at this
hopefully in parallel to what we saw
before let me move this a bit out of the
way you have a new graph but it's being
translated and in this case because a
equals five it's been translated five
units to the right so I can change this
of course I could for example move it
back over to the left if I had a
negative value for a like say let's put
it at negative oops I missed now you do
for I'm so bad my fingers are really
stubby three will do okay great so what
do I got here I've got X take away
negative three which can't say that that
double negative this is X plus three but
I like to think about it as X take away
negative three because what I'm really
doing is going negative three units to
the right which is the same as three
units to the left you can see the blue
graph being that new version over there
on the left hand side so again we can
come in and we can draw this let me come
over to my page and I hope you're doing
the same I've got the same parabola that
I had from up above but
I'm moving it I'm translating it a units
to the right so I'm going to do my best
to pop in a parabola there okay now this
point here I need to think for a moment
because just like before I don't just
have a new x-intercept I also have a new
y-intercept so the way that we find
y-intercepts is to let X equal 0 so if x
equals 0 then when I do that
substitution I'm going to have y equals
x take away zero sorry zero take away a
all squared I should write that down
zero take away a it's all squared so
I've got negative a squared the negative
cancels so that leaves me the y
intercept of a squared so there we go
I'm gonna pop that in on the y-axis okay
now this is as good a point as any to
pause and point out that for both the
first graph on the left hand side for
translation and this new one I haven't
put in a point for scale you saw I had
to just pick a point somewhere on the
graph and the reason why I don't need a
point for scale on either of these is
because once you have an x intercept and
a y intercept that aren't the same on
the origin this can't be any other graph
it's unambiguous so I don't need to find
some other points somewhere over here
and say oh where is this right the a and
the a squared on the x and y intercepts
on the x and y axes respectively
they give me enough information okay now
a B you've asked a question about down I
will come to down in a second we're just
not quite there yet
up and down we're just thinking about
horizontally at them and I'll explain
why as soon as we've done this last one
hopefully you can now start to predict
what is this last graph going to look
like maybe you're drawing it yeah this
is actually um it's a very perceptive
pick up we'll come back to it shortly I
promise because you're right it's
actually kind of interesting but up-down
and left-right in some contexts and
we'll explain what those are in a second
in some contexts can actually be the
same thing but we're getting ahead of
ourselves
spoilers ok so last time just on this
row right what am I doing here
in each case let me highlight it for you
I'm doing this minus a that's what I'm
doing algebraically you
can see it in here and then in here and
then lastly over here and in each of the
cases that's now confirm it for the
final one what we're seeing is let's go
up into that index change it to a three
I'll do the same over here change the
two or three okay let's put this back
over in the positive in each case what
we're seeing is a horizontal translation
now why should this be something we
actually expect why should this minus a
in the place that we've put it lead to a
horizontal transformation well let's
graph this along and then we'll um give
the explanation if I put that over there
why should we expect that a minus a in
the places that we've put them namely
here here and here
why should that lead to a horizontal
transformation well I want you to look
closely at where the minus a is in each
of these different equations there's
three of them right X minus a X minus a
or squared and then X minus a or cubed
that minus a what is it attached to and
the answer is in each of these cases
it's attached to the X right now the
x-axis is the horizontal axis so if we
have X take away a we should expect that
that change we're making should be
fiddling around with the X values which
is horizontally right now I know in the
case of y equals x minus a the very
first one it looks like it's an up-down
thing as well I'll come to that shortly
but I want you to see unambiguously for
the parabola and also for the cubic this
is definitely a left/right change yeah I
could mover over into the left if I made
a negative but all these examples here
just generally speaking I've moved over
to the right to a x equals a in this
case I'm gonna need negative a cubed as
my intercept okay